[Music]
Memorial Day is traditionally the
kickoff to the summer blockbuster season
and we have two titans going
head-to-head this weekend Pirates of the
Caribbean and Baywatch now working in
Baywatch is favorite besides the beaches
and the bodies is the bad guy who just
happens to be one of the most beautiful
women in the world Priyanka Chopra
you're never standing in the teach thank
you whoa whoa geez oh okay yeah
sexiest villains of all time where would
you rank yourself oh wow you can't ask
me to do like hell right I can't ask her
to rep you one then number one I don't
settle for less than that Priyanka is
Victoria the villain who poses a threat
to our Baywatch heroes some people are
up to no good makes me think about it
why am I so good at being bad mmm no
sexy red swimsuit for her every outfit
that Victoria wears has to be a power
suit you know every gown that she wears
she's just a power chick and you know I
have to feel that authority and
everything that I wore my heels had to
be super high speaking of power dressing
we'll never forget that Ralph Lauren
trench coat dress she wore on the steps
of the Met Gala I wanted to sort of have
a moment of rebellion on the carpet and
it was so sexy yeah of course I'm a girl
I wanted to be sexy
once Priyanka got inside the 20-foot
train came off and she partied the night
away in a trench mini dress I still
don't know where that the rest of my
outfit is who has your trench somebody
involved in fact vogue as one of their
73 questions to her wanted Priyanka s--
favorite memes of the outfit there was a
car I'm a cover of a car there's a tent
and then there's a magical flying carpet
how about the most common
mispronunciation of her name Bianca my
name starts with a P and her best
impression of the Baywatch theme
digitation
did it it is
[Music]
you